[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Chúng tôi có chức năng này được gọi là gạch bỏ.
Nếu tôi có một mảng thanh gồm 1,
2, 3, đúng.
Đây là mã cơ bản, tôi sẽ đảo ngược mảng và thêm nó vào chính nó, vì vậy
nó sẽ kết thúc là một cái gì đó giống như 1 cộng 3, mà sẽ là 4.
4, 4, làm tốt lắm Brian, bạn hiểu rồi.
Tôi không cố ý làm vậy nhưng về cơ bản, nó sẽ thêm 1 đến 3 và
2 đến 2 và 3 đến 1, phải không?
Vì vậy, nó sẽ thực hiện thuật toán vô dụng đó.
Nhưng hãy nói về cái cũ lớn đó sẽ như thế nào.
>> Brian Holt: Tốt cho mọi thứ mà chúng tôi nhập vào
bất kỳ độ dài đầu vào nào vì đầu vào của nó có thể là một mảng.
Nó sẽ chạm vào mọi thứ một lần.
Và chúng tôi đang làm những việc khác mà bạn có thể thêm.
Bạn có thể tìm ra các hệ số bằng cách thêm bao nhiêu hướng dẫn mà chúng tôi đang thực hiện
mỗi vòng lặp phải không?
Nhưng chúng ta không quan tâm đúng không?
Bây giờ là về các nét rộng.
>> Brian Holt: [COUGH] Xin lỗi.
Vì vậy, điểm chung ở đây là chúng ta sẽ thực hiện một vòng lặp lại mọi thứ,
về cơ bản nói rằng nó sẽ kết thúc.
Vì vậy, cứ mỗi độ dài, chúng ta sẽ xem qua một lần.
Vì vậy, bạn có thể nói ở đây rằng O lớn là M,
bởi vì chúng ta xem qua một lần, nó có ý nghĩa nào đó, phải không?
Khá đơn giản cho đến nay.
Vậy hãy nói về Tìm, đúng rồi, chúng ta mò kim đáy bể.
Haystack sẽ là một mảng và kim sẽ là bất cứ thứ gì bạn đang tìm kiếm
trong mảng.
Vì vậy, ở đây, chúng ta sẽ lặp lại nó.
Và nếu đống cỏ khô bằng kim thì chúng ta sẽ trả về true.
Thuật toán khá đơn giản.
Vậy, chữ O lớn ở đây là gì?
Chà, có khả năng nếu đó là lần đầu tiên,
nếu cây kim là thứ đầu tiên trong đống cỏ khô, nó có thể trở lại ngay lập tức.
Tuy nhiên, chúng tôi vẫn đang xem xét các khía cạnh rộng ở đây và
điều này sẽ giống như một nửa hoặc một phần tư n.
Nhưng bị cuốn vào những chi tiết không quan trọng đó, chúng tôi vẫn sẽ nói rằng đây là n,
nói cách khác, chúng tôi vẫn đang xem xét trường hợp xấu nhất và
trường hợp xấu nhất nó sẽ là điều cuối cùng đúng.
Chúng ta sẽ phải xem qua toàn bộ mảng.
Vì vậy, đây vẫn là O (n).
Vì vậy, ngay cả khi bạn đang đoản mạch, chúng tôi vẫn có khả năng
lặp lại mọi thứ và đó là khi tôi nói đó là một chữ O (n) lớn.
Được rồi, chúng ta hãy xem cái này ngay tại đây tạo bộ giá trị hoặc
lật đổ, tùy thuộc vào người bạn hỏi làm thế nào để nói điều đó.
Tôi nói chung là lật đổ bởi vì đó là những gì tôi nghe những người khác nói.
Và ý tưởng cơ bản ở đây là, chúng ta hãy xem.
>> Brian Holt: Nếu tôi có một cái gì đó giống như.
>> Brian Holt: 1,2, 3, nếu tôi có một mảng như vậy, về cơ bản tôi sẽ đi và
Tôi sẽ làm cho mọi sự kết hợp có thể có của các mảng mảng, đúng không.
Vì vậy, tôi sẽ làm 1,2.
Tôi sẽ làm 1,3 và sau đó,
Tôi sẽ làm 2,1.
Trên thực tế, tôi nghĩ nó thậm chí sẽ giống như 2,2, đúng, bất cứ điều gì.
Một cái gì đó có hiệu lực mặc dù
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, nó sẽ lặp lại mọi thứ và
sau đó tạo những gợn sóng này cho chúng tôi ngay.
Vì vậy, câu hỏi ở đây là O lớn của điều này là gì?
Chúng ta có một vòng lặp và sau đó là bên trong vòng lặp, vì vậy
về cơ bản, chúng ta đi đến một quyền trong mảng này và sau đó bên trong vòng lặp đó,
chúng tôi sẽ lặp lại mọi thứ bên trong vòng lặp đó, vì vậy
chúng ta sẽ làm một cái ở vòng ngoài và sau đó vòng bên trong sẽ làm 1,2,3.
Sau đó, chúng tôi sẽ làm 2, và
sau đó ở vòng lặp bên trong, chúng ta sẽ làm 1,2,3 một lần nữa, phải không?
Vì vậy, bây giờ bạn phải suy nghĩ về như, được rồi,
Tôi sẽ lặp lại nó bao nhiêu lần?
Chà, câu trả lời là, vì chúng ta có một bên ngoài và
chúng ta có một vòng lặp bên trong có nghĩa là chúng ta sẽ là n bình phương.
Và tôi hy vọng bạn đã thấy thủ thuật này, không có gì khác ngoài thủ thuật này,
bạn chỉ cần tìm các vòng lặp.
Vì vậy, mỗi khi bạn thấy lồng nhau một lúc hoặc một cái gì đó tương tự, rất có thể đó là
sẽ gần như không có gì đặc biệt, đó sẽ là câu trả lời của bạn ngay tại đó.
Vì vậy, bạn chỉ cần tìm các vòng lặp lồng nhau, nếu tôi có vòng lặp for trong vòng lặp for
vòng lặp trong vòng lặp for, nó sẽ được kết thúc bên phải, vân vân và vân vân.
Ngoài ra, nếu bạn có một thuật toán kết thúc, có thể bạn đang làm sai.
Tôi chỉ ném nó ra khỏi đó.
Rất hiếm có những dịp thích hợp.
Về cơ bản đó là nó ngay tại đây.
Chúng tôi chỉ tìm kiếm các vòng lặp lồng nhau,
bởi vì đó là 95% thời gian là những gì sẽ thêm nhiều thời gian nhất cho những gì bạn đang làm.
Và một điều đáng nói khác.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn không có vòng lặp và
nếu bạn chỉ làm điều gì đó đổi lại đó phải là thời gian không đổi.
Bởi vì hoặc 01, chúng ta luôn nghe nói về thời gian không đổi, vì vậy và
Tôi sẽ nói rằng ad nauseum khi chúng ta tiếp tục như vậy.
Ý tôi là thế.
Điều này có nghĩa là không có vòng lặp nào trong mã của bạn.
Chúng ta cũng sẽ thấy o (log n), khi chúng ta bắt đầu chuyển sang đệ quy và
thuật toán đệ quy.
Và về cơ bản, nếu bạn đang chơi đệ quy, một chiến lược đệ quy bất kỳ loại nào như
phân chia và chinh phục, điều mà chúng ta sẽ nói đến ở đây sau một chút.
Nó sẽ chỉ là một bản ghi đúng, và về cơ bản điều đó nói lên điều đó khi bạn thêm
ngày càng nhiều yếu tố đối với bất cứ điều gì bạn đang làm, nó sẽ mất ít hơn và
ít thời gian hơn cho mỗi mục mà bạn đang thêm vào danh sách, phải không?
Vì vậy, nếu có thể mười đầu tiên đưa tôi đến mười và sau đó mười tiếp theo khiến tôi mất năm giây để
mười tiếp theo mất hai giây rưỡi, phải không?
Vì vậy, đó là sự cộng thêm thời gian và đó là ý nghĩa của thời gian logarit.
>> Brian Holt: Vâng, với kích thước đầu vào.
Vì vậy, điều đó sẽ giống như sắp xếp hợp nhất và sắp xếp nhanh và
đối phó với cây cũng sẽ thấy các thông tin đăng nhập đệ quy này.
>> Người nói 2: Chúng tôi có một câu hỏi trực tuyến.
>> Brian Holt: Chắc chắn.
>> Người nói 2: Bạn có hay bạn muốn tôi đọc cho bạn nghe?
>> Brian Holt: Hãy tiếp tục, bạn đọc nó.
>> Người nói 2: Được rồi, có công bằng khi nói rằng nếu bạn phải lặp lại mảng hai lần,
bạn có thể có O 2n hoặc vẫn được viết thành O n?
>> Brian Holt: Đó là một câu hỏi hay.
Ai hỏi vậy?
Brody?
>> Diễn giả 2: Brody Y.
>> Brian Holt: Brody Y, được rồi.
Vì vậy, câu trả lời cho câu hỏi đó là bạn sẽ thêm một hệ số, nhưng khi chúng tôi
thấy trước đây với ba x bình phương cộng với x cộng một, chúng ta chỉ bỏ ba.
Vì vậy, O đó là khá hung dữ và hút đi tất cả các điều khoản khác.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi vẫn sẽ nói đó là O n, ngay cả khi bạn có vòng lặp like for và
sau đó là vòng lặp for khác bên dưới và vòng lặp for khác bên dưới.
Chúng tôi vẫn chỉ,
chúng tôi đang thêm các hệ số không thực sự thêm các điều khoản hoặc các điều khoản hàm mũ đúng không.
Nhưng đó là một câu hỏi tuyệt vời.